[Applause]
and finally new rule someone has to tell
me why is this guy always in the dog
house with the online hall monitors of
righteousness it is a phenomenon that
truly fascinates me that every couple
years matt damon
one of the most likable guys in
hollywood with impeccable liberal
credentials
is again flailing around in cancel
culture quicksand
it happened again this month when damon
revealed that he used to use a gay slur
i won't say the word but it's the one
your teenage son greets his friends with
when they meet up at chipotle
it's not always meant as a slur but it's
wrong yes of course and damon owned up
saying that while coming of age in
boston in the 70s and 80s that word was
thrown around without any thought put
into it and now
now he's put some thought into it and
he's going to stop using it one might
say he became woke
okay he was late to the party to which
we could say welcome glad you could make
it
or we could say you came later than i
did die
there are too many people in this
country who are motivated not by what
they really believe but by what will get
twitter to react to them with likes and
retweets that's called bad faith
it's why every couple years i'm reading
headlines like usa today i wish i could
cancel matt damon
washington post matt damon has more
damon splaining to do
bailey beast shut up matt damon
vox matt damon isn't a terrible person
he's just ignorant
really
that bad is he we're talking about matt
damon
i don't know he's got a clean water
charity and delivers food to haiti
what have you done vox headline writer
and yet he is always getting pulled over
by the woke police for something he's
got a woke rap sheet as long as your arm
on the reboot of the project green light
series he was booked on obstruction of
social justice for maintaining that a
director should be chosen on merit first
but merit first is not synonymous with
racism
thinking that it is that's kind of
racist
in 2015 damon did hard time in twitter
jail on two counts of accessory to
homophobia
for saying that actors do well when they
keep their private lives private so that
audiences can watch the character on the
screen without thinking about the
caricature from the tabloids and that
includes your sexuality
which is true one of the reasons i love
daniel day lewis is i'm not sure he even
exists off-screen
but in wokeville somehow that became gay
actors should go back in the closet
which is not what he said but the
verdict was in and he was sentenced to
appear on ellen
but here's how unhomophobic matt damon
is
he [ __ ] liberace
[Applause]
2016 the movie the great wall opened and
damon was brought up on charges of
whitewashing in the third degree
whitewashing being when filmmakers cast
white actors for parts meant for people
of color which is exactly what he was
not doing
his role was never meant for a chinese
actor in fact it was a chinese-made
movie targeted primarily to the chinese
audience that was purposefully using his
white ass
so the movie would have crossover appeal
here
nevertheless when i heard about this i
immediately replaced matt's poster over
my bed with chris evans
[Applause]
2017 in the early days of the me too
movement damon was locked up in wokatras
on a charge of aggravated mansplaining
during a reckoning
and was sentenced to not less than one
year of having to shut the [ __ ] up
see what happened was during an
interview where damon called the metoo
movement wonderful and a watershed
moment he added that sexual misconduct
involved a spectrum of behavior and that
there was a difference between patting
someone on the butt and rape
true
undeniable and unforgivable
even though the legal system has always
differentiated degrees for crimes even
murder
oh matt always getting in trouble for
saying perfectly reasonable things
and now
and now he's done it again by breaking
liam's law
yes that's the law that refers to the
time a few years back when actor liam
neeson recounted a story of personal
growth involving racist thoughts he had
as a young man but then realizing the
error of his ways expunging the racist
element from his anger
but of course in so doing he committed
the cardinal sin of admitting he was not
born perfect
and did not emerge from the womb
completely enlightened like buddha
[Laughter]
and now matt's done
donetic with his gay slur admission
committed the crime of not always being
the person you would become
you know i'm so tired of bad faith
arguments and it's all we do now on both
sides of our divide
two weeks ago nancy pelosi called
republican house leader kevin mccarthy a
[ __ ]
oh that's not the bad faith part of the
story that's the true part
[Applause]
but a few days later mccarthy was
speaking to a group of republicans and
said jokingly
but he is kevin mccarthy
he said that if republicans took the
house in 2022 quote i want you to watch
nancy pelosi hand me that gavel it will
be hard not to hit her with it
pelosi's office called it a threat of
violence
hakeem jeffrey said violence against
women is no laughing matter and eric
swalwell said mccarthy was a would-be
assailant who must resign
shut up
shut the [ __ ] up
[Applause]
this is what bad faith is you don't
really think it was a threat of violence
or that anyone thinks such violence
would be a laughing matter or that kevin
mccarthy is a would-be assailant any
more than anyone thinks matt damon's a
homophobe
and matt my advice to you
stop hunting for goodwill you're not
going to find much in this country
you